yesterday howard stern gave us plenty of
fodder for discussion today howard stern
had tom brady on his program for the
first time ever they went for two hours
there were some technical issues early
on derek jeter apparently hadn't paid
the wi-fi bill at the mansion in tampa
that tom brady is renting from him but
uh they they got into it and
what always happens with howard stern
he's a master at getting you
comfortable at getting you to the point
where you will talk about things to him
that you would never talk about publicly
with anyone and for some it it takes a
little more time but he seems to get
everyone to that point almost to the
point chris where you acknowledge going
in if you're going to be on howard
stern's show that at some point you're
going to open up because that's just
what happens and because he's developed
that reputation when you sign on for the
interview you assume at some point
you're going to bear your soul about
something you would never say in any
other setting
no i mean you're right it's the great
the greatness of howard stern i mean
it's delivered us so many classic
moments throughout the years and uh i
mean first off when you do an interview
that was what almost two hours long i
mean you're gonna have to get crazy and
open up i mean that's the one thing
that's the one thing i'm amazed by i'm
amazed that brady committed to do i'm
not amazed that he committed to do the
interview just amazed that he went for
that amount of time and went that deep
into his own personal life and
professionally and all that that was was
really cool we don't ever hear that from
tom brady and it's something that i
would like to hear more of as a fan of
his and and football in general so that
was it was a cool listen i didn't listen
to the whole thing i tried to just
listen to the important parts for now uh
but i really did enjoy it
one part that raised plenty of eyebrows
tom brady talking about his marriage to
gisele bundchen and he addressed
why
later in his career he had to stop
showing up for the otas gisele was not
happy with the way things were going
here's tom brady explaining what the
problem was and what he had to do about
it
you know a couple years ago we had you
know she didn't feel like i was doing my
part for the family
you know and she felt like i would play
football all season and she would take
care of the house
and then all of a sudden when the season
would end i'd be like great let me get
into all my other business activities
let me get into you know my football
training and she's sitting there going
well when are you going to do things for
for for the house when are you going to
take the kids to school and do that
because she's like i have goals and
dreams too it's just not to do these
things either so you you better start
you know taking care of things at the
house so two years ago as it related to
even football for me i had to make a big
transition in my life to say i can't do
all the things that i wanted to do for
football like i used to i need you know
i got to take care of things in my
family because my family was the
situation wasn't
great
we talked about this last hour chris you
preemptively called bs on the
explanation that that's why tom brady
stopped attending otas
i believe that that is why he stopped
attending otas i think that is a real
dynamic that can play out in any
marriage it's refreshing to see that
there's that same push and pull that
balance that we need to try to achieve
in any relationship like that where
there are obligations there are
responsibilities there is workload that
needs to be distributed and you need to
be present and if you're caught up in
the off season program even though
you're only there a few hours a day
you're all in with it if you're doing it
right and you're thinking about the next
day and you're preparing for the next
day you're absent physically and
mentally from what's going on in the
household and i think that she did
tell him it has to change and i don't
believe that this is some elaborate
cover for a middle finger to bill
belichick i really do believe that he
did what he had to do to ensure that he
had the right balance in his marriage
well listen i i don't deny that and i
certainly don't want to sit here i mean
i i know tom brady the person is a
really good person i mean he really is
he's a great father and you know
obviously you can see he aspires to be a
great husband and you know from
everything i know he is a great husband
now now to be transparent yes i had
heard there was little issues you know
if you remember back when like he was on
the airplane with ben affleck and his
babysitter and the babysitter of ben
affleck had all of tom brady's rings on
and things like that i think that was
probably caused some stir in the
marriage a little bit and i remember
hearing things at that time but mike i
mean
either all in or you're not i don't know
you're the quarterback i mean you'd say
it all the time and the quarterback
needs to be there and that's part of it
and i totally believe him in the fact
that yes he's tries and was doing his
best to do for the family but you know
again i just want to say otas are 12
days it's 12 days of the whole spring i
just have a hard time buying that listen
i think that he wanted to be the good
father and the good husband and that was
part of it but i also i'm just saying i
think part of it too was hey new england
i'm kind of sick of you always on my
back and not paying me to what i deserve
and this is his way of kind of doing
this without ruffling feathers too much
see i personally think that the push
began in the aftermath of super bowl 51
the 28-3 comeback by the patriots they
win it it's the year that began with tom
brady being suspended four games and
giselle bunchen recognized and she said
this at the time this is the perfect
time to walk away this is it what more
can you do well you can win another
super bowl and go to two more and maybe
do more in tampa but
that was the year if you remember chris
a few months later she was on cbs this
morning and and blurted out that tom has
had concussions and created that issue
there and i felt like that was kind of
her way
to publicly put a little pressure on him
to get closer to the point where they
have the right balance in their
relationship and he stops playing
football i mean i i assume when she
signed on to be tom brady's spouse she
believed that he would not be playing
football when he's 42 going on 43 so i
really do think and i think this is
refreshing you know i'm always
uncomfortable talking about people's
personal relationships but i think it's
refreshing because this guy comes off as
a robot right he comes off as someone
who is above the issues that affect
every other normal human being this is a
normal human issue that he had to
navigate and he talked yesterday that at
some point his wife wrote him a letter
explaining how she was upset with where
the relationship was and he decided he
was going to do what he had to do to get
things to where they needed to be and i
really don't think this was a power play
against the patriots now maybe it was
easier for him
to pick a side here he picked the right
side and it's easier to pick that side
when you understand that this patriots
machine is going to throw you overboard
the first chance it gets the first point
where it feels like it's in its best
interest to do so so yeah you can't pin
your loyalty to an organization that
ultimately isn't going to be loyal to
you because they're going to upgrade
over you when they know it's the right
time to do it so i i just i think that
that this to me was the most human we've
ever seen tom brady what do you have
gone to otas this year mike in tampa is
he not going to go to otas this year
well i i
i uh yes i know he was gonna be there he
was gonna be there wait so yeah can i
can i'm trying to gather my thoughts
you're not giving me a can i can i can i
i'm doing what you do to me usually
that's what i'm doing nobody gets to
spend more time as a professional
athlete as home than football players
they spend eight nights a year on the
road they're home all the time i know
he's an awesome father and trying to be
an awesome husband i'm not denying that
i'm just saying listen you're gonna play
quarterback this is what you got to do
and to me that was the start of the end
because you know a place like new
england with the kraft family and the
belichick family you know that's hey
it's business they want to play football
and you got to be there and i'm sure
that didn't sit well with them either
here's my guess and this is just a
complete and total throw the dart guess
my guess is
that behind the scenes
maybe she's been advocating for him to
make a change of scenery maybe she's
been advocating for him to jump before
he gets pushed because she's been
hearing over the years the anxiety and
the concern from him that at some point
this belichick character is going to say
we're done with you so
from the standpoint of that balance
right we we're trying to balance things
out in the relationship she gets a
little bit of a victory when he leaves
the patriots and goes to the buccaneers
and they're in florida close to costa
rica close to miami close to brazil
so the balance back would have been he
gets to go to otas because if he wants
to vindicate himself for leaving he
needs to be fully prepared he needs to
be ready to go so this year he'd get to
be all in for otas that's my assessment
of it yeah good job good job gathering
your thoughts there very very well done
i like do you agree do you agree with
what i do you agree with what i said i
think there's some truth to that i do
think there's some truth to that yes i
would think as a wife who and it seems
like they they're in a very good
relationship and honest and open and
everything like that i'm sure she saw
the stress
uh that the new england patriots
organization put on tom brady the daily
uh having to prove himself have to prove
to my coach that i'm still worthy of
being the starting quarterback and yes
any normal human being even tom brady is
going to take some of those frustrations
homes at home with you at times to where
it filters into the house i mean you
know i get frustrated with you sometimes
i come home and it filters through my
house for a little bit so i'm sure it
happened with him and bill belichick
you do
no not really
see that but but that's the ultimate
test that's the ultimate test
of whether or not this relationship
between us works because
my wife really likes you and i think
your wife really likes me and if either
of us were spending our time saying i
can't believe that no good sob and i
can't believe he does this and he does
this
it's going to affect it's going to
affect how the spouse views that person
oh you got the whole family in man you
know aunt wendy she's buying stock and
mike florio dirty diana sims my mom
she's all in on you even you even
converted the big effort even big phil
you got him now where he's like i want
to go do the show with you i want to do
the show with mike alone i don't even
watch you there and i'm like oh okay dad
thanks so you got my family on a hook
we're very well done mr florio
but that's the point though we have the
relationship where it's not going to
spark the kind of stuff that gets the
spouse upset
with the other side of the relationship
it happened with gisele and tom all
right we're going to play another clip
before we take our break the issue of
concussions i talked about that earlier
where gisele let the cat out of the bag
three years ago here's howard stern and
tom brady talking about the extent to
which tom has suffered brain injuries
during his career
have you had concussions yeah i've
definitely had concussions playing
you don't sit there and sweat that at
your age i could sit here and go well
stop playing football so i could you
know worry about what's going to happen
or worry about this or that instead of
saying you know why don't i live my life
the way that i want and enjoy it in the
ways that are going to be most
fulfilling to me which for me is doing
what i love to do you don't tell
musicians stop singing you know at age
of 42 you don't tell a great painter
stop painting at 42. now if you want to
stop stop go ahead
but for me
because i feel like i can still play
doesn't mean i should just stop playing
because that's what everyone's telling
me to do
kind of a stupid argument because
continuing to play professional athletes
is tied to having the physical ability
and the physical abilities begin to
erode a painter can paint as long as the
painter's alive for other things you can
do it as long as you can can work your
brain and work your body to you know
hold the brush or do whatever it is that
you do for football those skills go away
he's already five or six years into
house money and this idea and i like i
like the the the stubbornness because
that's one of the reasons why he's still
playing chris
he can just play as long as he wants to
play is it realistic at some point
father time will win
yeah right i mean it's catching up to
him we know that but he still feels like
he's got good football left in inside of
him and i you know i believe that too i
do and i think this you know this move
this switch will kind of reinvigorate
him in a lot of ways too you know to
prove the haters wrong he wants to make
sure it goes the right way all of that
so
uh yeah i get that you know brady you
know it is it's what's made him great
he's mentally tough he's physically
tough and he loves playing football and
he loves what you know more importantly
the game is the easy part he loves the
work that you have to put into it to be
great on sunday and that's really where
he's special it's easy to play the games
on sunday mike you know hey anybody can
play the real job is what are you doing
monday through saturday that's the work
that's where you earn your paycheck the
game is fun and you just let it fly and
brady is one of those guys that's been
willing to sacrifice that and really i
think he's a guy that looks at it and
you know i know i'm kind of like this
where i'd go man i'd rather have you
know 65 70 great years than you know 90
years and i think he's not worried about
that if it means an extra concussion or
two i don't think he gives a damn quite
frankly uh and i think there's a lot of
football players that are kind of out
out there like that
you've said before he will have that arm
into his 50s the legs are what we need
to watch especially in the bruce aryan's
offense because no risk it no biscuit
throw the ball down the field you hold
the ball a little bit longer and you may
get hit a little bit more often and
that's what you need to watch if you
can't move away from pressure that's
when the beginning of the end will come
for tom brady
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports